(coup de klaxon)
- Après des mois sur pause,
Toronto commence à redevenir
une ville en ébullition.
Mais avec ce retour à la normale
vient le constat que le paysage
du centre-ville a changé.
Beaucoup de petits commerces
n'ont pas survécu et ont été
remplacés par de nouveaux
joueurs : les magasins
de cannabis, qui ont poussé
comme des champignons
pendant le confinement.
- Entre Spadina et Bathurst,
il y en a une dizaine déjà.
- Le quartier de Shamez Amlani
a accueilli beaucoup de
ces nouvelles boutiques
et a perdu toutes sortes
de commerces indépendants.
SHAMEZ AMLANI, propriétaire
du restaurant La Palette
- Magasin de tapis, magasin
de meubles d'occasion, bar, etc.
N'importe... ils remplacent
tout, quoi.
- Le restauraurateur, qui est
établi sur la rue Queen West
depuis 20 ans, déplore
ce changement et décrit même
un phénomène d'embourgeoisement.
- Il y a pas mal d'argent
derrière ça, donc ils peuvent
rester avec les portes ouvertes
même s'ils ne sont pas
très occupés.
- Shamez Amlani n'est pas
le seul à s'inquiéter du nombre
grandissant de commerces
de cannabis à Toronto.
À quelques mètres de
son restaurant, le propriétaire
d'un magasin de vêtements
fait le même constat.
"C'est difficile, ça rend
la rue un peu ennuyeuse",
lâche l'entrepreneur.
Au Québec, on compte
un grand total de
78 succursales de la SQDC.
À Toronto seulement,
où la vente de cannabis
relève entièrement du privé,
il y a près de 200 boutiques.
Et la tendance s'est nettement
accélérée dans la dernière
année. En 2021, 163 permis
ont déjà été octroyés.
Ce magasin de cannabis
fait partie de ceux qui ont
récemment ouvert leurs portes.
Le groupe détient six magasins
au total et va en ouvrir quatre
autres à Toronto cette année.
"Les affaires vont assez bien",
affirme la PDG du groupe
Superette.
Mais même les représentants
de l'industrie admettent que
la prolifération de magasins
peut paraître choquante et que
le temps dira quels joueurs
parviendront à survivre.
Cette conseillère municipale
ne pense pas que la demande
pour des produits de cannabis
justifie l'offre excessive,
surtout dans le centre-ville de
Toronto, où les loyers peuvent
facilement coûter des dizaines
de milliers de dollars par mois.
Devant l'ampleur du phénomène,
Kristyn Wong-Tam demande
à la province d'intervenir
et de geler l'octroi de permis.
De son côté, le gouvernement
provincial dit ne pas avoir
l'intention d'apporter de
changements à son modèle
de distribution de permis.
Pour ceux qui voudraient voir
moins de magasins de cannabis
en Ontario, il ne reste donc
qu'à espérer un changement
de cap du gouvernement ou
que la loi du marché finisse
par éliminer les commerces
moins compétitifs.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, Toronto.